[Music]
anybody has been to Colombia the first
thing you see are our libraries you see
low library see popular library what
people sometimes don't realize is why it
is we have so many of them and the
reason is because information is growing
so the freedom of information archive is
the world's largest database of
declassified documents when the freedom
information archive first began back in
2013 the government created some 90
million new secrets over the years
there's been exponential growth in
official secrecy we realized that if we
could begin to aggregate those
collections and put them into a single
database we could begin to discover
things about history and we could also
begin to discover things about
government secrecy the idea is that we
can use data science to accelerate the
review of sensitive information and
accelerate also the release of
information that doesn't need to be
protected anyone can access the project
by going to history labs org once you're
there in our website you'll be able to
search through several collections of
declassified documents we've put
together a set of really powerful tools
that gives users the ability to use the
cutting-edge technology coming out of
data science to explore that archive
knowledge is power
yes we move forward is very important
that we share our knowledge with each
other particularly if we're seeking a
world where all of us can share in its
wealth collaboration is key more and
more Columbia libraries is becoming a
place for making and doing it's a place
where Columbia professors students
librarians archivists can come together
and build things the freedom of
information archive is one of the things
that we've been able to build because of
the Columbia libraries because of the
space that it provides and the platform
that it has provided for all of us to
support these kinds of projects Columbia
libraries through projects like the
freedom of information
is showing the way for libraries all
over the world so it's all the more
important than that Columbia libraries
and I hope more libraries begin to see
that that mission of collecting
government information making available
to the public is more important than
it's ever been
before we are thinking about the larger
infrastructure of knowledge around the
world we must constantly innovate and
constantly change in order to with that
especially now during the digital era
where this new forms presented new
challenges libraries will be there right
at the avant-garde trying to make sure
that our present today is there for the
future